the simple life and we may know what you  did before you got me for a lid I was a  pip you know like Gladys Knight in the  pits a secret past Robert you were the  best if anyone could have figured a way  out of living you I tried to stay away  it comes a point you have to help people  cuz you can make the start I me about a  girl 16 seconds 19 seconds I promised  someone that I love I would never go  back to being that person but today I  make an exception  he didn't take out five MCS weren't  random criminals be afraid to sing with  his skill I want to know we really it  everybody wants to know  no I'm offering you a chance to do the  right thing  take it with equalizer rated R